it's been over 200 million years since
south america broke off africa into its
own continent
but now it's behaving very strangely
it's taking on water and
going down
how would this whole continent turn into
a sinking ship
what effect would this have on the rest
of the world
and how would you and everyone else
manage to escape
this is what if and here's what would
happen if south america disappeared
earth's crust consists of moving
tectonic plates that rest on the hot
molten rock of the mantle below
classified as either continental or
oceanic there are somewhere between 15
to 20 of these plates
and they fit together just like pieces
of a jigsaw puzzle
only these puzzle pieces happen to pull
apart and collide with each other from
time to time in a movement called
tectonic shift
the south america plate which includes
the continent and a large part of the
atlantic ocean is the smallest of all
the major tectonic plates
and it moves at a rate of about three
centimeters every year
that's about as fast as your fingernails
grow
this slow pace may not seem like any big
deal except that this makes the south
america plate collide with the nazca
plate on the western side
and this slow motion collision has been
causing massive earthquakes
like the 9.5 magnitude quake that shook
chile in 1960
and today it's going to send nearly half
a billion people fleeing from the now
sinking continent
when a continental plate like south
america meets an oceanic plate like
nasca
one of these plates begins to submerge
under the other
this is known as subduction
and for these two plates it's happening
at a rate of 8 to 10 centimeters every
year
usually if an oceanic plate collides
with a continental plate it's the
oceanic one that goes down but
if the rolls were reversed it would be
mayhem
as the south american plate began to
sink the nazca plate would be getting
sucked over it
you could see a new trench form in the
ocean
it would be as deep if not deeper than
the mariana trench
but this subduction wouldn't go smoothly
actually it would be quite the opposite
the plates could get stuck
and this would build up a lot of
pressure along the fault line between
them
when the stress became too great the
plates would break free and all that
stored up energy would be released as
seismic waves
you'd need to prepare for some extremely
destructive volcanic eruptions
earthquakes and tsunamis
this region already sits along the
andean volcanic belt
known for its major volcanic activity
it's caused by the nazca plate already
sinking underneath the south american
one
flip the script and things could get
even crazier
imagine all these volcanoes becoming
active at once
you and the other 120 million people
living in countries like colombia chile
and peru would be displaced by these
disasters
and there would be a lot more lost than
just homes
we'd lose unesco world heritage sites
like the ancient city of machu picchu
or the incredibly beautiful city of
cartagena
and maybe worst of all you'd see the
amazon rainforest disappear
this place is home to 10 percent of all
species of plant and animal life on
earth
it would mean mass extinction and it
would have enormous and far-reaching
impacts on other ecosystems around the
world
with the amazon gone there would be
fewer trees to produce the oxygen you
breathe
of course you'd see the global markets
and supply chains take a devastating hit
too
argentina and brazil produce over half
of the world's soy
no longer able to rely on this source of
animal feed countries around the world
would suffer food shortages
and not only that but without south
america you'd face a serious shortage of
black gold
and no i don't mean oil
brazil and colombia account for 25
of the world's coffee exports
you better get used to not having your
morning cup of joe
in the end as the south american plate
slips lower and lower you would see the
entire population of the continent
displaced
that's about 438
million people
there's no country or continent on earth
that could accept them all at once
but hold on time for a reality check
south america isn't really slipping into
the mantle of the earth so this kind of
population relocation number crunching
shouldn't be too high on your worry list
besides it would be nothing compared to
the nearly 1.2 billion people expected
to be displaced due to climate related
events by the year 2050
maybe all those volcanoes erupting at
once could actually help us avoid that
problem
but
that's a story
for another
[Music]